got a
shotgun we're going to have to take him
out you ready put your hands up put your
hands right conf back to back officer
involves shootings in Phoenix just one
day apart both shootings caught on body
cam put your hands up your hands
right
move the first happened on January 11th
when a welfare call came in to Phoenix
PD a woman reported her mother's
neighbor hadn't been seen in days and
his home was flooding Phoenix police
this is how can I help you um hi um one
of my mom's neighbors um she hasn't seen
him for a week and then there's water
running out of their house and it's like
flooding and she tried to like go knock
and everything to see um if they're okay
but nobody's answering the door body
camera video shows two officers arrive
on the scene and approach the door you
can see water trickling down down in the
background and hear the rush of
flooding there's twoes
com officers call out making their
presence known Phoenix Police Department
anybody
inside I don't smell anything
cigarettes the first officer calls out
again and this time the homeowner
answers Phoenix Police Department yeah
oh hello how you doing huh we got a call
cuz the water was looking they thought
somebody they hadn't seen
the I'm I'm taking I'm irrigating here
what's that I'm irrigating it's more
than irrigating the house is
leaking like it's coming look like it's
coming out from underneath the house and
then it leaking back here I got I I I'm
working on it the officer then asks the
homeowner just show his hands you a
favor I can't see your hands or anything
like that can I see your other hand what
you doing my back cuz I'm doing to check
welfare the officer asks again but this
time the man draws a gun put your hands
up put your hands right can see the
homeowner and a second officer then
exchanged gunfire this body camera video
shows the entire situation from another
angle the perspective of the officer who
would later fire off his weapon Police
Department anybody
inside
Police
Department
I can't see your hand or anything that
other
hand I do Che your hands up here's the
moment leading up to the shooting from
the other officer's Viewpoint your hand
like video also captures the officer
scrambling a bit after the
shooting additional officers eventually
arrived on the scene where they found
the homeowner dead inside officials also
recovered a handgun on the scene and
noted that the man fired multiple rounds
at the responding officers highspeed
chases T we got a unruly suspects I will
kill that mothers me no do it stay in
the bo I like K dramatic DUI I'mma pass
everything that she trying to do and
shocking body cam footage hey kill the
ground kill the ground law and crime
presents body cam the place for real raw
and wild police videos you should have
seen it it was good it's on body camera
I'll show it to you catch the action and
subscribe to our new YouTube channel
now the very next day another officer
involved shooting in the
[Music]
City Phoenix officers responded to a
call on January 12th for a domestic
violence emergency here's a clip of the
911 call so what's he doing um right now
he's banging on the he's banging on the
door okay with a
knife so with a knife yeah okay does
anybody live in this apartment do you
know yes yes uh they had a um domestic
violence about a week ago when officers
arrived to the apartment building where
the incident happened the suspect was
gone nearby they caught up with a
suspect who refused to stop when they
called
out
stop right
there stop right there put your hands up
in the air you will get
hurt put your hands in the air or you
will get
hurt while trying to get the man to stop
walking officers used less lethal
options including pepper balls and 40 mm
foam balls both were shot toward the
suspect as a way to slow him down but he
didn't
stop
yeah
right will be
hurt he's still walking
away get on the ground
it all this continues as an officer
fires more pepper balls at the s supect
but he still doesn't slow
down during this time security video
captures the suspect on cam pointing a
gun at officers meanwhile a lieutenant
arrives on the scene this body camera
video shows his
perspective he just the gun at
me
probably
people
[Music]
are
playing as the video shows he grabs a
shotgun from the back seat of his Squad
the Lieutenant asks other officers on
the scene to confirm who the suspect is
before opening fire is that him running
in the
P go 77 is that
him
[Music]
this video shows the moments after he
fired the
shot
move moments after the lieutenant fired
a shot at the suspect a separate officer
who had previously fired off the foam
balls ran his vehicle into the suspect
he's trying to head back to the victim
apartment just running with gun dude
just
stop get
closer there's a house in the back got a
shotgun we're going to have to take him
out you ready shoot your red I'm
on watch the
civilians he's reloading too got to move
after the shooting the suspect was taken
to the hospital to be treated for severe
injury
investigators later determined the gun
he had was actually a pellet gun made to
look like a semi-automatic they also
determined this suspect was not the man
involved in the domestic violence
situation earlier that guy was tracked
down though and he was also booked both
of these officer involved shootings are
now under investigation and will be sent
to the Maricopa County Attorney's Office
for review once they're complete
reporting for La crime I'm Sierra
Gillespie